where is our teachers living they can't
afford to live here we are funding
education 49th in the nation you want to
talk about new york and california and
other states that have we're the third
largest gdp in the nation third after
those two states but yet we're funding
education 49th in the nation that tells
you that our priorities are backwards
and our education system is falling
apart
healthcare we're funding healthcare 50th
in the nation
we haven't expanded medicaid so well i'm
curious though because you mentioned
education that's that's a topic near and
dear to me i was a teacher for many
years um so what is your what is your
fix to that because i know that desantis
has been out there talking about school
choice and that's a topic many parents
are passionate about because they're
concerned about their ability whether
they have money or not some don't have
money but they want to be able to send
their kids to the schools that they want
to send them to what is your fix to an
educational system that's broken in
florida well first of all we as
floridians voted for the lottery
to make sure that lottery money was to
go towards education and that was
supposed to be in addition to
so back in 2006 we had per pupil funding
at around 6 400. we're at 6 900 today
between 2006 and 2022 if you look at
inflation it should be over ten thousand
dollars just to keep up with inflation
so what we have done is we have gutted
our traditional public schools and i'm a
proud proud product of our public
education system in miami-dade county as
was my parents they all were also from
the miami dade and what we've done is we
have gutted our traditional public
schools and so we've taken money out of
our our traditional public schools and
we have allocated into
any other place not even not even just
general other education we've gutted it
and so what we have to be doing is
putting more money back into our
education system okay so i'm going to
tell you though money's not going to fix
the educational system because new york
places like that have been funneling
money into education for decades and
decades it doesn't work the way that you
fix an educational system is the way
that you fix every system as you put
competition into that system and you
force you force those schools to fire
bad teachers to pay good teachers higher
you you force those parents to have the
option to choose where they send their
kids to school every single district you
look at everywhere in the country that
allows for school choice sees a rise in
educational opportunities for families
and a rise in standard of education for
kids so if you want to fix the
educational system truly and i believe
that you do based on what you're saying
that's how you fix it well and i don't
necessarily agree with all of that you
know but she makes a good point though
and i don't have kids just like you i
don't i mean but school choice seems
like capitalism at its finest what's
wrong with that
because everybody is entitled to a
quality education system and when you
take money out of our traditional public
schools which are still the bedrock most
if you talk about people wanting to go
into choice if you look at the
statistics still 75 plus percent of our
parents are still making the choice to
put their kids into public traditional
public schools and they're failing them
those schools are failing them but
that's also because the fact is that if
you were talking about our private
schools or charter schools that are
paying more money for their teachers
that we're losing we have 6 500 shortage
of teachers that we are asking parents
to come in as substitute teachers
they're making nothing they're making
nothing indicating those salaries i know
what they look like and so was my mom
you know she taught for 25 years i heard
those stories heard the stories of our
teachers buying school supplies for
their kids because there's not enough
school supplies in the classrooms and
and what we have done is is money enough
no absolutely but that has to start
somewhere that we have schools and you
want to look at something interesting
that at a third grade reading
that 90 percent of our black kids at
third grade reading are reading below
poverty line and we are we base where
how many jails and prisons we built
based on that third grade third grade
reading but you can't blame first of all
you're gonna have to look at family
structures for that you're gonna have to
go back to the dinner table you're gonna
have to look at is that does that child
have the
support we can go into that hope you
have to talk about community you have to
talk about church i mean there's there
are layers deep of this of course but
you're not going to throw money at that
at that school and fix that kid you're
going to the way that you're going to
give that kid an opportunity let that
parent or that guardian pick where that
kid goes to school and if that school is
failing that kid shut her down shut her
down why wouldn't money help though if
like if you're saying teacher's gonna
come out of pocket to buy because you
know why they waste a ton of money like
every other government institution they
waste a ton of money you don't see it
and then you have teachers unions you
don't agree with that nikki you don't
think government
oh government that wastes lots of money
the governor just did 109 billion dollar
budget i can find a whole lot more he'd
only be to a 3.1 billion i could have
vetoed a whole heck of a lot more in
there there you go so an education no no
military i don't care what department
you're talking about every single
institution of government there is waste
there's fraud there's abuse education is
part of that of course and look i have
put forth my i oversee a 1.3 billion
dollar budget inside the department of
agriculture every single every single
session i've put forth a more
conservative budget than my republican
predecessors did because i didn't want
to waste money i made sure that we had
the exact money that we needed to run
the department and the programs that we
needed to do to whether it's increasing
um our the amount of money that's coming
in for agriculture to making sure our
water quality is in there i asked for 83
new positions for concealed weapons
programming because again we have the
largest concealed weapons program in the
entire country here in the state of
florida that i regulate i ask for 83
more positions because we are
overwhelmed and the governor vetoed
those 83 positions because he has his
own agenda so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]